- Hawaii, California, Nevada,
Brazil, and Australia.
These places have one very
flammable thing in common:
invasive grasses.
These plants are fueling more frequent
and faster burning fires
that are harder to put out
and potentially more
catastrophic to human life.
I'm gonna show you how and
what's being done to fix it.
Grasses are considered invasive
when they take over new ecosystems
where they don't belong.
Cheatgrass, which now blankets the basins
of the American West,
originally came from
either Europe or Eurasia.
And guinea and buffelgrasses,
which likely played a big
role in the lahaina fire
are from Africa.
Invasive grasses are among
the most ignitable fuels
for fires.
- Look at the grasses.
It's like a lot of gasoline on the ground.
- Unlike the leaves of
trees or other plants,
grass doesn't decompose very quickly.
It can stick around for a long time.
Because their leaves are so thin,
grasses also dry out fast,
making them extra flammable.
- If the air is hot and dry,
they will come to zero
moisture content, right?
And if you have a fire
coming down a mountain
or a power line falling into dry grass,
it's gonna ignite instantly.
- Just look back at places
where we've seen intense
grass-fed fires lately
or even the recent
fires in Canada, Greece,
and Washington State.
Dry weather is a huge contributor,
and experts say dry seasons
are becoming longer and more
extreme due to climate change.
Under those conditions,
grasses can really show
how well they thrive
even in extreme environments.
Their seeds can sprout
plants very, very quickly.
- You get a little bit of
rain, boom, they're off.
- Their shallow roots also expand fast,
meaning they can grab
water from a large area,
often way faster than native plants.
That puts native species
at a disadvantage.
Add fire to the mix,
and that handicap grows
because invasive grasses
are very resilient to fire.
So after it all burns...
- All that comes back is grass.
- That's happening a
lot across the country.
Without taller trees and shrubs
acting like windbreakers,
wind speeds go up.
That fans fires and
helps them move faster,
making them harder to control.
In other words,
invasive grass is not only fuel fires,
they also make the
environments they invade
more fire-friendly.
It's called the grass-fire cycle,
but human activity is
making grass-fueled fires
more problematic and potentially deadly.
All of a sudden, we're
seeing a lot more fires
in places where you wouldn't expect them,
like deserts.
One big issue is land use
for housing and agriculture.
More people live in
close proximity to areas
that are fire-prone.
- In California, there's a lot more people
moving into lowland areas.
- [Daniela] On December 30th, 2021,
the Marshall Fire started
near Boulder, Colorado.
- It was a fire that started in dry grass
that was completely surrounding
a housing development,
very similar to the Maui situation
that it didn't have to go very far
before it hit the first house.
- 1,084 houses went up in flames.
The Marshall Fire got
started from burning trash
and a power line that emit sparks.
In Maui, abandoned pineapple
and sugarcane fields
filled up with guinea and buffelgrasses.
These invasive grasses
then likely fueled the fire
that destroyed Lahaina.
Another important variable is emissions.
All over the US,
modern vehicles with combustion
engines spread out ammonia,
which is the nitrogen
source that grasses love.
It's the building block
of nitrogen-based commercial fertilizers.
- We're creating a really nice environment
for them to grow in.
- So, does this mean
that devastating fires
like the ones in Hawaii and Colorado
are going to become more common?
- It's a preview of what happens
when you are not prepared
and when you are not
planning for the extreme.
- Things like rebuilding roads
to make evacuations easier
and retrofitting houses
to make them resilient
in a more flammable world.
Other survival strategies
include controlled burns
of grass-invaded areas
and then planting
less-flammable vegetation.
Community preparedness is also critical.
- We need to imagine
our worst-case scenario
and then say, "Okay, are we ready?"